[Musique]
au moment où s'ouvre la campagne
présidentielle je voudrais français
française vous demandez à tous sans
distinction d'opinion d'avoir une pensée
pour le général de gaulle il a refusé la
défaite incarné la résistance et la
libération il n'a cessé de dénoncer les
faiblesses
l'impuissance d'un régime dont les
hommes tous presque sans exception sont
venus un jour de 1958 lui demandait de
sauver la république et de résoudre le
drame algérien la république a été sauvé
le drame algérien a été résolu au prix
je sais la souffrance elle sacrifices
pour les français d'algérie et le pays
ne doit pas l'oublier mais enfin pour la
première fois depuis plus de 50 ans nos
soldats vos fils vos frères vos maris ne
se bat plus nulle pas sur la tête c'est
dire combien la tâche de qui prendra la
suite par est écrasant et pourtant je
suis candidat et je vais vous dire que
pendant longtemps vous le savez
peut-être je n'ai pas désirer une
carrière politique
acte i et puis en 1962 le général de
gaulle m'a nommé d'emblée premier mini
j'ai fait mon apprentissage j'ai fait
défaut comme tout le monde mais je ne
crois pas avoir été indigne de ma
fonction est d'ailleurs le chef de
l'état
deux assemblées successivement il pays
chaque fois qu'il a été consultée d'une
façon ou de l'eau ou d'une autre ont
confirmé ou même accru leur confiant et
pendant toute cette période
chaque fois qu'on parlait de succession
et de dauphins et dieu sait si la presse
en parlait eh bien je ressentais plutôt
une impression des fronts et puis est
venue mai 1968 l'agitation university
qui se développait partout dans le monde
à paris a pris une ampleur un prof je me
trouvais malheureusement en voyage
officiel loin de la france
et quand je suis revenue j'ai trouvé
paris et reset barricades
la grève générale proclamée des milliers
des dizaines de milliers de gens qui
défilaient derrière des drapeaux rouge
et des drapeaux noirs et un complot
politique qui s'ébauche est et l'un se
présentait déjà comme président de la
république et offrez à l'autre je t'ai
monsieur mendès-france déjà d'être sans
premier ministre il fallait qu il
fallait d'abord rétablir l'ordre
progressivement mais fermement et sans
faire couler le sang
sans nous jeter dans la guerre si il
fallait remettre la france au travail et
ce furent les discussions longues nuits
de grenelle vous vous en souvenez
et puis des accords qui ont je crois
donner satisfaction à beaucoup de
travail est et puis il fallait déjouer
le complot politique
faire comprendre à l'opinion ce qui se
passait
jusqu'au jour où le chef de l'état dans
un appel historique pu renverser la
situation c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
compris quand viendrait le jour
je n'aurais pas le droit de me dérober
je suis donc candidat et je voudrais
vous dire deux choses d'abord je n'y
mettrais pas le style du général nous ne
le pourrait d'ailleurs
et puis vous le voyez bien je suis un
homme différent
je me propose une politique d'ouverture
et de dialogue d'ouverture cela veut
dire qu'en gouvernement rénové se
reposant sur une malle majorité très
large étendue à tous ceux qui acceptent
les principes essentiels de la vème
république dialogue
cela veut dire des rapports constants
confiant entre le gouvernement et le
parlement assemblée et sénat avec tous
les élus les élus locaux en particulier
et avec le pays car j'ai l'intention de
lui expliquer fréquemment simplement
franchement la politique est
naturellement de permettre aux
oppositions dans la critique
tout cela pour quoi
et bien pour maintenir la dignité et
l'indépendance de la france sur laquelle
repose notre paie d'abord mais aussi
pour me pencher sur les difficultés
quotidiennes les préoccupations de
chaque foyer
il faut réaliser une expansion rapide
permettant de développer la justice
sociale d'assurer l'emploi de défendre
la monnaie il faut faire une france
moderne et en même temps ne pas oublier
que la solidarité nationale doit jouer
pour les régions déshéritées les
catégories défavorisées les profession
menacée mais tout cela ne sera pas
facile
il y aura naturellement des difficultés
techniques il faut que l'administration
ne viennent plus souple plus efficace
moins tatillonnes eux d'ailleurs la
plupart des fonctionnaires l'immense
majorité des fonctionnaires le souhaite
il faut avoir à sa disposition les
moyens financiers administratifs
économiques mais il faut aussi avoir les
moyens politiques
il faut que le nouveau président puisse
d'emblée avec un gouvernement rénové
reposant sur une majorité très large
s'atteler à la tâche car la situation
actuelle ne vous y trompez
au départ est d'un calme factice en
période électorale
chacun se garde bien de faire peur mais
nous le savons bien des difficultés se
prépare dans l'université l'agitation
persiste elle ne demande qu'à exploser
ici ou là en amorce des revendications
on prépare des grèves peut-être du
désordre est en tout cas comment
pourrait-on réaliser tout ce qui lie à
faire s'il fallait se heurter à des
difficultés politiques un gouvernement
composé de bric et de broc aller vers la
dissolution vers de nouvelles secousses
de nouveaux retards alors croyez moi
nous nous préparions un mauvais été
dangereuse automne mai 1968 il y a à
peine un an
ne l'oubliez pas français français je
suis un démocrate je crois êtres humains
et libéral je crois aussi et je le dis
sans vanité
soyez en sûr être capable de fermeté et
l'avoir prouvé pour préparer des
lendemains qui peuvent être qu'ils
doivent être heureux mais qui peuvent
être dangereux j'ai l'honneur de
solliciter vos suffrages
[Musique]